Nếu tổ thương mại đã phát tính nhận định sang gia như thuộc sử lúc Trung Quốc,
hoặc dầu thôi libang ngà khi dí chuyển qua vùng biển biển bình đỏ và biển bắt ư.
Theo ăn tiền Rhoi Tơ s, biển này nhằm chẳng định nhằm là tổn phương tay,
hoặc có linh hệ với yên xeran giữa lúc xung đầu tại chúng đồng liều thang.
Chứ đó, lần lộng hôm chiều giấy mẹn đồng minh của yên raan,
liên tục tấn công các tổn phương tay để phản đối chính xe quân sự quý xeran tại giải ca gia.
Yên raan cũng đây soạn đăng cười ở biển Homos,
nếu mẹ thì tổ hỗ trợ các cuộc không thích quý xeran nhằm vào trề raan,
dù một thổ thận bắn tạm thời đứng đự thiết lập,
các công ty vẫn tải vẫn lo ngại dù giòn tại khu vực.
Phản đứng trước tình hành để bằng ngà tuyên bố sáng sản chình khai hại quân
để bảo vệ tượng gió hành hại,
đồng thời chỉ chỉ có lạnh trường phạt của Phương tay là hành vi ke biển.
Chứ khi đó, ai ui tục mọi giòn sân xe tổ biển trường phạt,
biên quán đến Más Ké Và.
Dù lộng có tế cho sang việc giảm ảo tin nhiều,
cho thấy miếc cơ ăn linh hình hành hành đang làm dòng,
và chứ có giấu hiệu hành như trong thời gian tối.